Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for our 50th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
BAU!
The 50th episode!
Right!
Suddenly!
We're here!
50!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Moco-chan!
Wow.
Just because today is the 50th episode doesn't mean it might not be your first episode.
Right!
Exactly.
Ruffians, if you're joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Or a.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FUWAMOCOMORNING!
FWMCMORNING!
Even if it's the 50th time.
Still can't quite do it.
It's a learning process.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
I got distracted.
Ruffians.
Ruffians are distracting Moco-chan.
There's too many colors.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
Ruffians, you've been keeping your eyes open, right?
Maybe you've been seeing Pero around a little bit.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
It's good to know that he's still doing okay, but I hope that everything's going okay for you, Ruffians.
Sometimes maybe it's a not-so-great thing.
Did you see him again?
Well, today we have a Ruffian that spotted him.
Let's see where he is!
De-den!
Huh?
Hi.
Pero's gone!
Hi!
You found Pero in your kitchen?
Maybe he got hungry.
It looks like he got stuck in a container of... Lard.
That lard is fat, right?
Who's fat though?
I don't know.
I'm concerned.
It looks white.
Maybe.
Is it Pero's fat?
It's the same color.
Well, if it was his, couldn't he squeeze it out of himself and into the container and then escape?
You know he'd be a few pounds lighter, right?
Right?
That could work, Ruffians!
This is how we're gonna start off episode 50!
This is how we're gonna do it!
If I was in a situation... Eww!
Eww!
Yes!
I don't know, I'd be careful, you know?
Not only Pero was sitting in there, but that line might be also from him, you know?
Pero Lord.
I don't think Pero hibernates though.
Maybe he's just kind of looking to get a bit fluffy before the cold temperatures get really cold in the Northwest Passage.
I don't know.
It's not really necessary if he's going all over the place in the human world now, right?
Because he went to Florida, right?
But maybe it's just a seasonal habit he just can't shake off now.
Poor Pero.
Oh well.
We hope that you threw out the lard afterwards, okay?
Please throw it out.
It's not good to eat.
No, we're consuming that.
But we still didn't know who's fat it was in the first place, right?
Garbage.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians are really fighting peril in a lot of different places.
That's weird.
But!
Happy news!
Ruffians!
I know you let us know yesterday, but our brand new cover song of Kanae's Identity has hit 200,000 views!
Thank you, BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for loving it lots and lots, Ruffians!
It's only been three days, so we've really been listening to it lots.
Right.
We're so fast, right?
We've seen so many really nice comments, and it really warmed our hearts.
Yeah, it makes us want to sing so much more.
All for you, Ruffians.
Thank you.
You know, we know, you know.
We know, we know, we know what?
We know you know how much it means to us, but really, really, thank you!
BAU BAU!
Please look forward to more cover songs and music in the future, okay?
Wow, Ruffians!
There's also something else that we kind of heard about.
We heard about it.
I didn't think... Wow.
I'm a bit surprised about this one.
A bit surprised!
No, we heard... We were nominated for the VTuber Awards!
Yes!
You know, we are just newbies, but we are nominated for this for a category called League of Their Own.
You know, you can vote for which Vtuber you feel most fits the prestigious titles they have, and in this category, there are three others, including Marine-senchou-senpai!
You know it!
That's pretty amazing.
I don't know.
You know, we're still brand new.
It's hard to compare us to such an amazing senpai.
But you know!
Before, we talked to Mane-chan about how we really admire Mane-senshu-senpai and we really want to be doing amazing things like her when we're seniors like her too!
Yeah, when we're seniors too.
But, you know, it is true though.
We're very much something different for better or for worse.
You know, Shiori and Yappi, twin demon white dog sisters that like to BAU BAU!
Hold a morning show like this one three times a week, you know.
We play games in our own unique FUWAMOCO way!
You know, Metal Gear Solid and Least About Us.
Sneaking.
Yes.
You know, we sing songs very silly multiple times a month.
Very silly.
Yeah, you know, we do things a bit out of the box like telling your spooky stories and you know, whatnot.
Those kind of things because
We feel really strongly that you are a part of this, Ruffians, you know?
A part of our journey.
You're a part of us, you know?
But, I guess FUWAMOCO, we're one and only.
Or two and only.
Two and only.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm FUWAMOCO!
We also hope that maybe it could be to lead to more Ruffians.
New Ruffians finding us too!
Please check it out, okay?
Awesome!
Many of our wonderful senpai have been nominated for other categories too!
But Advent's own gaming rug, Biboo, has been nominated for Gamer of the Year.
Although you should look for Bijou.
Bijou, yeah.
You might get confused.
Yeah.
But we're really happy!
She's definitely the gamer of our heart and she really rocks.
So she's got our vote for sure!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Please don't forget you can vote right now at their website, thevtuberawards.com.
If you would like to.
We would like that if you voted for us.
Right?
If you would like to.
BAU BAU!
Happy!
Advent, we're still just newbies, but yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, we have some interesting news for you, huh, Ruffians?
Ruffians, you know, sometimes we mention Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy, right?
Right.
Sometimes.
Yeah, they like games and video games.
Not card games, video games.
But card games too, I guess.
Card games too, yeah, that's true.
And you know, books and science fiction and all those kind of good stuff.
And you know, they're very obviously very important to us too.
We love them.
Yeah.
Do we have a picture, Moco-chan?
My picture is not a secret.
This is what they look like.
There's us there too.
But you know, I guess we talked about before how they only BAU BAU and they're not very good at English.
And that's why they can't make their appearance here with us, you know?
Yeah, dull appearances.
Yeah, but Mama Puppy has been practicing her English recently.
Thought that maybe, maybe you'd be happy if you could meet them one day.
So, we have something to announce.
Something to announce!
If we reach our goal of a certain amount of Ruffians subscribed to our channel, Mama Puppy will make a guest appearance!
Yeah!
Papa Puppy's appearance is TBD.
TBD.
Yeah, you know Papa Puppy's a bit of a rough Papa Puppy and shy, too.
A bit shy.
But!
That goal... Are you ready, Ruffians?
The goal, do you want to hear the goal?
That goal...
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Yeah, 5 million!
You heard right, Nerissa!
5 million!
Yes!
Motainai!
E chigau no e!
Mama Puppy still has a lot of English to learn, okay?
She does, yeah.
Papa puppy has a bit shy.
BAU BAU!
That's exciting!
Exciting, right?
Exciting!
Not 5 trillion, it's just 5 million, okay?
We can count the many days, weeks, months, years, decades, right?
5 million is not that much.
Right.
Mama Puppy we're talking about, okay?
Mama Puppy.
Yeah, you know, it does take quite some time to learn some new tricks, right?
Yeah, okay.
Sorry, Mama Puppy.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, today's our special 50th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
To be honest,
We wanted things to be different, but... We wanted to do things differently today, but... Well... Sometimes things don't quite go as planned.
And there's been another misunderstanding.
There's been another misunderstanding.
You know, Moco-chan... Moco-chan got a bit tongue-tied.
And, uh... You said something... Uh... Well...
Moco-chan didn't really know what she wanted to say in English the other day.
We finished the game, but we finished Metal Gear Solid, right?
But...
So then Moco-chan said what she wanted to say in Japanese.
Oh, yeah.
That is just normal, you know.
And usually Fuwawa will help me.
It's normal for that to happen, right?
Yeah.
And I'll help, but... I think this time, Ruffians, there was a lot of you thinking that I was being mean and said something totally wrong!
But I wasn't!
I was trying to help.
No.
Yeah.
Well, Moco-chan, what did you say?
Well, I said... I said... Nametara akan yo.
You know, which is like, don't underestimate me or look down on me.
But, Fuwawa helped by translating it as
I was just helping, you know.
It's actually the same, Ruffian!
So, Japanese has different ways of writing things.
So the first one, it's in hiragana, and the second one is in kanji.
So you can tell the difference.
They have different meanings, okay?
You can tell from the context too!
But, I guess it could also be a play on words sometimes.
Yeah, and you know,
I was just a bit confused.
Were you really confused?
I was!
So don't think I'm a bad sister or anything, okay?
Ruffians!
Don't misunderstand, okay?
It's cleared up now.
Yeah, machigayasui!
It's easy to make a mistake like this, okay?
Ruffians, remember!
Nametara akai iro!
BAU BAU!
No misunderstanding now!
No misunderstandings.
You got it?
It's a bit of a lesson as well, okay?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Well, to make up for the misunderstanding, I guess.
Is it okay to share with the Ruffians?
I guess.
The other day, you might know from Twitter that
Something good happened.
Yeah, something very good happened, Ruffians!
It arrived!
A present.
From YouTube!
Ruffians!
I saw my play button arrive!
Thank you so much again!
We tried to take a good photo without our reflections but...
But, you know, we're so thankful for your support.
For all of our senpai's hard work too.
And to be able to call hololive our home now.
Thank you!
And Ruffians, look!
We even received two of them!
We don't even have to share!
We didn't even have to ask either!
It really, really warmed our hearts.
Thank you so much everyone!
Thank you!
We're continuing to wait.
Can we take a photo with them?
It's kind of funny we're taking a photo with a photo.
It's a photo with a photo.
Yeah.
That means there's two Fuwawa and two Moco-chan.
That's not going to be confusing.
Maybe.
Well, Ruffians.
We're gonna continue to work really hard and hopefully one day we can receive our Golden Play Button too!
BAU BAU!
So exciting, right?
Exciting!
We're not trapped in it.
Trapped!
It's just a reflection, silly.
A reflection.
This is really shiny, you know?
You could use it as a mirror.
You could, you could.
Ruffians, you all know that today is a very special FUWAMOCO Morning.
Just a bit, right.
After all, you know, it's our 50th episode!
Yeah, and you know it's a very special morning show to all of us.
Actually, we received some cute video messages from all of our fans!
BAU BAU!
Let's check them out!
Is it okay?
Who's first?
Let's see!
Good morning, FUWAMOCO.
Oh man, I probably just woke up for this.
FUWAMOCO Mornings.
Oh good golly, I don't know how you guys do it.
Waking up that early.
Oh my good lord.
But, but, I'm super proud of you.
Congrats on reaching your 50th FUWAMOCO Morning.
You guys are fantastic.
Genmates, I'm super happy to have you.
Out of jail.
Out of jail, walking the park.
Even though you guys keep chasing the mailman who just tries to deliver us our crap.
Thank you for being really kind to us.
And you guys are super sweet.
Oh, by the way, thanks for introducing me to pon-de-rings.
Oh man, those are pretty yummy.
I don't think mine are legit pon-de-rings.
I don't know.
Mine go like hard.
They go hardcore.
Like cobra hardcore.
After like a few days.
Or maybe it's my fault because I don't eat them in time.
Why are you letting them sit for a few days?
Yeah, pon-de-rings?
Super yummy.
I hope that you guys will be able to get more rest.
I'm watching you.
And I look forward to seeing more FUWAMOCO Mornings.
I don't know about you, but I prefer sleeping in until 1pm or something.
However, I'm getting a little bit better.
I'm getting a little bit better.
I'm waking up before 12pm now.
Yeah, that's right.
Shiori, oh no.
She's becoming a morning person.
But, but, but.
Make sure to take care of yourself.
Eat your breakfast.
Take care of your voice.
Make sure to do doggy stuff like doggy walks and doggy paddle and doggy biting the mailman's butt.
Shiori!
BAU BAU!
Shiori.
Shiori's so sweet.
Not as sweet as Pon-de-ring, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Not as sweet as Pon-de-ring.
Yeah, I wanna eat Shiori.
I wanna eat Pon-de-ring.
Not Shiori.
Pon-de-ring with Shiori!
Pon-de-ring with Shiori.
No cannibalism, that's on Friday.
That's not this day, no.
Today's Wednesday!
But you know what?
Sometimes after FUWAMOCO Morning, Shiori will message me and be like, good job, FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's very cute.
I wonder on those days, is Shiori just waking up?
Or is she just sleeping?
I imagine if she's in bed and she's like, Oh, it's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Maybe there's a lot of Ruffians too!
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I imagine.
Thank you, Shiori!
Thank you, BAU BAU!
We also got some other videos because just Shiori doesn't make all of them, right?
Let's see who we have next!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Mococo.
I'm Nerissa.
Together we are FUWAMOCO-rissa.
Jokes aside, congratulations FUWAMOCO for your
50th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
That is such an amazing number to reach for any series, especially long running, and something you started from debut.
I'm so, so proud of you guys for starting this, for keeping it going for so long, and for helping Ruffians and other hololive fans have such wonderful mornings, being able to spend them with the two most adorable puppies in hololive English -Advent-.
But I'm not just here to congratulate you,
BAU!
And I was so impressed by your guys' vocals!
I mean, I always am, but I was so impressed.
The high notes were hit so well and you guys just sounded so good together, which is to be expected.
But I'm really proud of you guys and all the progress you've been making on your channel, with your music, everything, everything, everything.
And I hope, I know,
I'm excited and I'm sure the Ruffians are as well for everything you guys are going to do in the future.
So congratulations again on your 50th episode and I'll talk to you guys all soon.
Thank you!
We still have a kiss at the end!
That was fun.
For what?
For your tummy?
No!
I don't think it was for the Ruffians.
The kiss was for you!
Ha.
But thank you!
Thank you Abyssgard!
We're really happy to hear that you really like identity and that you like the song Tweets because you know that's always an area of...
FUWAMOCO is FUWAMOCO.
Nerissa, you think too, okay?
If we're gonna do this, you have to pull your weight too.
Start thinking, okay?
Thank you so much, Nerissa!
BAU BAU!
I actually had an idea, but then recently I've been thinking...
No.
Why?
Just cause.
Maybe not.
This is why I said that it's so difficult to choose.
Right?
There must be something better.
Well!
We have another video.
No more.
No more videos.
No!
Advent's not complete without Biboo too!
Can I see a video from Biboo?
BAU BAU!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
Hi!
It's Biboo, and I would like to congratulate you on your 50th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
50, wow!
Congratulations!
To make your 50th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning more special, I decided to present a special segment today I would like to call Biboo's Meme Corner!
Meme Corner!
Now, recently there's been a meme going around that has now gotten into around hololive because of a certain rock.
And that meme is Gyat for the Rizzler.
There was a recent parody of it.
A certain member may have sang a hololive version of it.
And FUWAMOCO said... It's cute!
BAU BAU.
We don't understand the joke, but that's okay.
Yeah, that's okay!
Because I'm going to explain you the song.
So, the first line of the song.
Sticking out your gyat for Nerissa.
What does that mean?
The original is sticking out your gyat for the Rizzler.
The Rizzler is someone with Riz.
Someone with Rizla.
So obviously that is Nerissa.
And sticking out your gyat is basically sticking out your butt.
So you are sticking out your butt.
For Nerissa.
Okay, moving on.
I'll pass on that, thank you.
You're so BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
The original one is You're So Skibbity.
Skibbity is a popular song, but it's just fun to sing.
And you know what else is fun to say?
BAU BAU?
BAU BAU.
Thank you!
They're both catchy.
Don't you so skibbity?
You're so BAU BAU.
I think BAU BAU is just much better.
You're so bibutax.
Why?
I still don't know what this means, but bibutax.
Let's say bibutax is you are exchanging a little bit of your sanity while watching me.
Yes, in exchange for watching bibu, you exchange some of your sanity.
I never feel like that.
Maybe I lost all my sanity.
I just wanna be your Shiori.
Now, the original is I wanna be your Sigma.
And Sigma is like a macho person.
And Shiori is like the best.
Right?
Everyone wants to be Shiori because she's so cool.
So that's basically it.
That's basically it.
You understand?
No.
You understand the meme?
Not at all.
You understand now?
No.
I like the you're so BAU BAU part.
BAU BAU.
Maybe you don't, but that's okay.
Because the whole part of what makes the meme the meme is that no one can understand what the beep anyone is talking about.
Done!
I hope that clears it up.
Thank you for coming to Biboo's Meme Corner.
I hope you learned something today and BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Did we learn something, Ruffians?
I like that you're so BAU BAU for it.
You're so BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
You learned so much.
I learned that maybe we don't need our sanity anymore.
Because apparently, you lose sanity watching people, and apparently you didn't need any anyways to learn that.
Right!
What's the point?
The point is for you not to understand.
Don't think just
Just Biboo.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Biboo!
You can always count on Biboo for being... Even though she's a rock, you know?
She's up to deep.
Up to deep.
No nose.
What is that?
No, she has a nose.
She knows what the heart thing is.
You know?
The finger on the pulse.
Yeah.
Thank you Biboo for doing your best to teach us about the new things.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Advent!
We're so lucky.
Yeah, it means so much to us.
Right, you know?
All your videos.
Thank you!
We know, you know, that Advent, they've really helped us out a lot while, you know, we struggled through things these past four months, you know?
Especially with our worries often about FUWAMOCO Morning.
You know, we've talked about it before, but even though it might not look like it, there's actually a lot of work that goes into each episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
You know we wake up at 5am for it and some days we weren't able to wake up for it because we were working through the night.
There's definitely been times where we felt very not good, a bit unwell, and like, I just can't do it today, you know?
We're not able to do it, but we've pulled through because we know that you'll be pulling yourself out of bed, and you're looking forward to seeing us before you go off on your day too, right?
You know, we want to make sure that you're going to be on the right paw with a smile on your face and we hope that maybe we can make the day just a bit brighter for you too.
Just a bit.
So, no matter how rough it is, we continue on!
Continue!
Even though there are times where we feel like we just can't do it too.
You know, there's been numerous times where we've even talked between the two of us about maybe ending FUWAMOCO Morning
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for waking up with us three times a week and being here to support us.
It really, really does mean the world to us.
But if somehow the day comes where we have to put a pause on FUWAMOCO Morning,
Please understand that it was not a decision made lightly at all.
There were many tears involved too, so... Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for 50 episodes!
And many more to come!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO-chan, you know we receive so much strength and power and support from the Ruffians all the time, right?
I do.
Do you think that
Maybe you can give the Ruffians some of that power back too?
Would you like that?
Well maybe if you don't even like it.
I don't know.
Even if you don't like it.
I wanted to tell you something today!
It's straight from my heart, so... You better listen up, okay?
Do you know what time it is?
Do you know what this is?
This here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Yo!
Ruffians!
I know it's rough sometimes.
I know it's hard to keep going.
Sometimes...
You just want to sleep without the weight of knowing when you need to get up and get going.
But, despite all that, you're doing it!
You managed to keep going!
You keep bringing your absolute best to each and every day!
You know, not every day will be as good as the last, but what I can promise is that you'll make it through.
You'll make through it!
Now, we're already at almost the end of the year!
We're almost there!
In the blink of an eye, 2023 has gone by this fast!
I know that things haven't gone exactly as you planned or hoped, but you've done amazing.
Don't focus on what didn't happen or what you didn't do.
And think about all the things that you did do, okay?
What you accomplished.
What you challenged yourself to.
What you're still challenging yourself to, bit by bit, every day.
Okay?
I'm not lying when I say that you're amazing.
I believe in you, so you should do okay!
It's all gonna be okay!
Let's work hard together.
Got it.
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Let's do our best, okay, Ruffians?
At FUWAMOCO, we'll continue to do our best on every each next episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO-chan, do we have a Doggie of the Day for today?
We do!
The Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Haku!
That's a cute name.
Why?
Very, very cute.
Haku is a quiet dog like us two, but he looks...
I know.
He looks kinda like us too, no?
Kinda like us.
A little bit more snow-colored than Rai.
Yeah, a little bit more caramel-y in comparison, I think.
But even though he's a good dog, he's a super softy too.
Yeah, me BUBUBU.
I don't think we're BUBUBU.
Why not boop boop boop?
Don't boop us, okay?
Yeah, but you know, we're not scared to get mean if those who are important to us are in danger.
Especially your smile.
You should know that by now.
But, you know, Haku looks very serious here.
Maybe a seriously silly Haku.
I wonder what happens if I touch the nose.
I don't know.
Let's maybe go find out, Moco-chan.
How does Haku BAU BAU?
Maybe a bit scary, a bit rough like a BAU!
Wow, Haku is everything you could want in a kaito!
You might seem a bit scary at first, but it's actually
BAU BAU!
Good buddy.
And for today, I went on a walk.
Where did we go on a walk to?
We have the...
Maybe we're looking at the same moon.
Well, Northwest Passage is a bit different, so maybe not.
Maybe not, but I wanna believe that!
Yeah!
Let's believe that, okay?
This is why morning walks are so nice.
Yeah!
Story notes!
It's so crisp and peaceful.
Quiet.
The world's just waking up.
Everything is shining.
Quiet.
And anything is possible for you to accomplish with the rest of your day, right?
We hope it gave you a good boost of energy for the morning.
BAU BAU!
I want to use that as a wallpaper.
I know, right?
I like the color.
It's like ice cream.
I want to eat the ice cream sky.
Ice cream sky.
Well, for the Question of the Day today, we have... De-den!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
Well, there are a lot of things that can brighten up our day.
You know, nice weather, good cup of tea, restful sleep, doing stretches, good walks.
You know, lots of stuff.
But!
The best is seeing special comments and sweet messages left by the Ruffians!
Especially on things that we worked really hard on.
And just Ruffians being silly and kind all together!
You know, we saw a Ruffian that was having a bit of a bad day on Twitter the other day.
There were a bunch of Ruffians all there with some genuine and really comforting words for them.
It made us really happy to see that.
Ruffians, you really are wonderful.
We're really lucky, Moco-chan.
We really hope that you can come together as a warm community of friends.
Even make amazing things happen, Ruffians, you know.
We know that you're super creative.
Especially when you're crazy.
You know, when you're passionate about something.
I guess the short answer is the kind words and actions that we see from the Ruffians.
That's what really brightens up our days.
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for all of your submissions today!
And for all of your submissions up until now, Ruffians!
Including the ones that still have yet to be featured, too!
And please remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together with you, Ruffians!
We're looking for more Doggie of the Day.
Maybe you see a really fluffy dog.
I know.
Or maybe a dog with no fur.
Oh, maybe.
No.
But I'm sure maybe you're going on a few walks here and there.
Show us what you thought was cool, you know?
And questions, questions.
I know you have questions.
As well as... We maybe have answers.
We have times that you see Pero too.
So please, please let us know and use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
For our next stream, we actually have something a bit different.
Yeah.
Well, we won't be having a stream tonight, but we will be making our first appearance on the official hololive English channel with
Very special announcement about the recent hololive English concert, Connect the World!
It premieres at 6.20pm PT or 11.20am GST, so please check it out!
Also, there will be a special announcement too, so please be there!
BAU BAU!
Exciting, exciting!
Look at us in the thumbnail there!
My eyes are so shiny.
That's what actually happened.
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, we have FUWAMOCO Morning 51!
FUWAMOCO Morning continues on, so we hope that you'll be there on Friday with us.
And if we take a little peek at the schedule too,
Llamas.
Something like that.
Yeah.
Limes are cute.
Definitely no cannibalism.
Let's hope the movie goes well!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
That was a surprise!
Ruffians, you surprised us there!
BAU BAU!
Thank you again, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 50th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
It really means so much to us that you want to start out your day together with us!
Thank you, Ruffians.
We hope that you'll continue to want to be here with us for many, many more mornings to come.
But, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Night Owl!
BAU BAU!
Marina!
Chihuahuan!
BAU BAU!
Ellipsis!
Hi Jeff.
BAU BAU!
Pilot AM.
Kousuke.
BAU BAU!
Agai.
Henkusa.
BAU BAU!
Astray Blue.
Tears!
BAU BAU!
Morning!
Mark, mark, mark!
BAU BAU!
Poison!
Yachi!
BAU BAU!
Mr. Madness!
Aspire!
BAU BAU!
Garnock!
Otium!
BAU BAU!
Kaizen!
Kochi!
BAU BAU!
Fugetsu.
Shuu.
BAU BAU!
Rush.
Torch.
BAU BAU!
Black Knight.
Witch of Madness.
BAU BAU!
Senzu.
Otomeru.
BAU BAU!
Rui.
Yui.
BAU BAU!
Belly Boy!
No Jet Plane!
BAU BAU!
Muyo-san!
Kemakatsu!
BAU BAU!
Grill Jones!
Akuma!
BAU BAU!
Mami!
Akarin!
BAU BAU!
By the Kings!
Swampin!
BAU BAU!
Whis!
Stay Gray!
BAU BAU!
Hello there!
Jeffy!
BAU BAU!
Piano.
Miracle Hunter.
BAU BAU!
Kizusango.
Duck Chopper.
BAU BAU!
Alexis Geyser.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FN-50!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!